Hello students. Welcome
to Pharmacokinetics.
We will be
talking about the
properties of
absorption, distribution,
metabolism, and
excretion. In this first
part, it will just
be absorption and
distribution. Dr.
Goldstein speaking.
Please contact
me if you'd
like a pharmacology chat.
Recall the pharmacokinetics
pharmacodynamics
relationship. The drug
gets into the body,
gets distributed, goes
to the pharmacologic
site of action, produces
its effect, whether
it's a therapeutic
effect or an adverse
effect. There is some
sort of a clinical
response And that could
be effectiveness, the
goal, or toxicity,
something to be minimized.
The processes of
pharmacokinetics are
absorption, indicated here
by input, distribution,
and elimination. So
elimination would be
biotransformation, in
other words, metabolism
to an inactive
metabolite or excreted.
The key factor?
Concentration. The
concentration in the
plasma will determine
the concentration at
the site of action and
that will determine
the magnitude of the
pharmacologic effect.
So,
how important really
is pharmacokinetics?
It is the pharmacokinetic
properties of
drugs that influence
efficacy and safety.
The goal of therapy
is to increase the
probability of therapeutic
success, and this
is going to depend
on the dose and
certain other factors,
and to reduce the
occurrence of adverse
effects in the body.
Sometimes we can't
stop them, but we can
at least minimize them
and mitigate them.
Here are the
learning objectives,
and it's all related to
mechanisms,
mechanisms, mechanisms.
Please read these over.
You don't need me
to read them to you.
Preparation materials.
The only thing
that I require
is the practice
questions.
These are case vignettes
and thought problems.
I will help you
to apply the basic
concepts of pharmacology
through practice
questions. And when you
receive the answers,
then you will
see the thought
processes and
this will help you
to really learn
pharmacology.
Here are some
resources if you
choose to use them.
I provided the
links. They are
all available.
These textbook
resources are all
available in our
medical library.
I've provided
some hints to help
you to actually
master a topic
to avoid the
illusion of knowing.
You may find them
helpful as you go
through this difficult
material. The material
itself isn't
difficult, it's just
that you get so much
of it all at once.
And here are some tips.
I really would like
you to try them out.
Rephrase the main
ideas in your own
words. It's about
your own words.
You can make a
question out of them.
That helps you
think about it.
Relate the ideas
to what you
already know and
that will help
make it stick
in your brain.
And here are
some techniques.
The definitions
are here to help
you with the language
of pharmacology,
the language of medicine.
More terms.
I've provided this
overview of really
of what you need to
know and understand.
So you can focus
on these concepts
and that will answer
your question of
what do I need to
know for the test.
And I have several slides
of concepts for you.
So let us begin.
The basic idea is
a drug is given at
some particular dose.
And how do we know
what dose to give?
We look it up in the
drug monograph and
that will guide us.
But we still have to
remember about our
individual patient and
there may need to be
adjustments of the doses
that are recommended.
In the case of oral
drugs especially, they
have to be liberated
out of their tablet or
capsule or whatever
form they're going in.
And then the drug
itself must be absorbed.
If we're giving
it by intravenous
administration, it's just
going straight
into the vein.
An oral drug needs to
pass through the liver
and then it will
go to the central
compartment, and that
is the bloodstream
and the highly
perfused organs.
If it is an IV
drug, it just goes
straight into the
central compartment.
Once there, the free
drug will then move
to the site of
action, move to be
stuck on tissue
macromolecules, they call
that tissue
reservoirs, can move to
areas that are not the
therapeutic target,
but rather produce
adverse effects.
Notice these
two-way arrows.
The drug will move in and
out, in and
out, in and out.
the drug can be bound
to plasma proteins
and if it's bound to
plasma proteins it will
be riding around on
the protein bus in
the bloodstream and it
will not move to the
site of action until
it gets off the bus.
It can bind to the same
idea of these inert
molecules in the tissues,
the same concept.
Even an IV drug or
anything that bypasses
the liver first and
goes to the central
compartment will
certainly pass through the
liver where it will
undergo metabolism.
And then the
metabolites, and that can
include a metabolite
that's actually
active, toxic or
inactive, will move into
the central compartment
again from the
liver where it will
go to be excreted,
but it may also be
excreted straight
out of the liver to
the biliary system.
So that's another
route of excretion.
So this very simple
figure really
sums up absorption,
distribution,
metabolism, and
excretion, and
how all are related
to each other.
A drug must withstand
digestive fluids
and enzymes. We're
talking about drugs
that are swallowed
into the GI tract and
the digestive fluids
and enzymes are in
the stomach. The drug
must move into the
intestine where it
will be absorbed and
once it's absorbed
it has and once it's
the intestine it has
to be able to cross
the physiologic
barriers to be absorbed
and to be distributed
to the site of action.
The drug must be
able to exit the
site of action
after providing
the specific
therapeutic effect
and it must be
eliminated either by
metabolism to inactive
metabolites which is
certainly the most
common, or it actually
may be metabolized to
an active metabolite
or a toxic metabolite.
In any case,
if it's metabolized to
an active metabolite,
that will terminate
the drug effect,
and that is equivalent
to elimination
via metabolism.
The drug needs to
be excreted and this
is by far most frequently
via the kidney.
By far.
In the kidney,
through the kidney,
inactive metabolites
or unchanged drug
may pass through
or active metabolites
and then be excreted
via the urine.
Let's begin with
absorption. The movement
of substances
across physiologic
barriers into the
central circulation and
of course we're talking
about the drugs.
There are a
number of ways to
pass through
physiologic barriers.
Passive diffusion
through the membrane,
the lipophilic
membrane, is the most
frequent method
of diffusion, of
passage through the
physiologic barriers.
Other mechanisms that
many drugs may be
using are through
transporters. So we see all
these various types
of transporters listed
here. I won't go into
it now because I'll
be talking about that
a little bit later.
Another way is for
molecules that are
dissolved in the plasma,
small molecules, can
pass between cells,
paracellular transport,
by solvent drag.
So first let's
talk about passive
diffusion of the
lipid-soluble
drugs across
cell membranes.
The key driver is
the concentration
gradient. The
drug will pass
down an area of
high concentration
to an area of low
concentration.
When the number of
molecules on one side
equals the number
of molecules on the
other side, It will be
in a dynamic equilibrium,
and there will be
no net movement.
The rate, in
pharmacokinetics, we're
talking about rate,
and we will also talk
about the extent,
how much, how fast
and how much the
drug molecules move.
So the rate and
extent of the flow of
the drug molecules
are influenced by
the magnitude of
the concentration
gradient across the
membrane. The greater
the gradient, the
faster the rate.
The lipid water
partition coefficient
of the drug will
determine its ability
to get through
this lipid layer.
The membrane surface
area of the drug,
so how much of the
membrane is available
for passage? Is
it a large amount
or is it just
maybe, let's use the
other side, just
maybe a small amount?
the permeability of the
membrane and
the thickness.
If it's a thick
membrane, let's make a
thick membrane, versus
a thin membrane, it
will take longer to
pass through the thick
membrane than thin
membrane. So all kinds
of different features
of the membrane
determine the rate and
extent of the flow.
This is the basic
concept that describes
the movement of drug
across the membrane,
across the physiologic
barrier. You do not
need to memorize
this equation, this
relationship, but you
should recognize, This is
the takeaway, that
diffusion across the lipid
bilayer of cell
membranes depends on the
drug's lipid water
partition coefficient.
And that is going
to determine how
readily the drug
enters the lipid
membrane from the
aqueous medium.
It's related to
the concentration
gradient, the area, the
permeability, and
the thickness.
of the drug and
the membrane.
Weak acids and weak
bases, the Henderson
-Hasselbalch equation
and ion trapping.
For weak acids and
weak bases, the pKa
of the drug and the
pH of the medium
determine the ratio
of molecules in
the charged or
ionized form compared
to the uncharged and
non-ionized form.
Here is the key.
The uncharged, non
-ionized form is the more
lipid-soluble form of
the drug. So a weak
acid and weak bases
dissociate in fluid.
They dissociate to
an uncharged form and
a charged form. It
is the uncharged form
that will pass
through the membranes.
Now, a greater
fraction of the weak
acid will be in the
lipid-soluble form
in the more acidic
medium, where the
pH is lower than
the pKa of the drug.
A greater fraction
of the weak base
will be in the lipid
-soluble B form, you
notice there's no
proton on there,
in a more alkaline
medium where the pH
is greater than the
pKa of the drug.
I'm sure you're familiar
with the Henderson
-Hasselbalch equation.
What we're looking at
in pharmacology is the
ratio of the unprotonated
form to the protonated
form. How much
of the drug, of a weak
acid or weak base,
is going to pass through
the lipid membrane?
We know the pH.
pH is very in the
body. We think about
plasma as 7.4, plasma
and interstitial
fluids as 7.4, so
we know the pH,
and we know the
pKa of the drug, so
that leaves the ratio
to be determined.
To repeat,
the lower the pH
relative to the
pKa, the greater
will be the fraction
of drug in the
protonated form.
Weak acids are
not ionized when
they're protonated
and that's indicated
by A for acid
and H for proton.
Weak bases are
ionized when they are
protonated. B for
base and H for proton.
Key concept.
Here it is illustrated.
We have our
lipid bilayer.
We have our different
body compartments.
The non-ionized
form of the, sorry,
the ionized form of
the acid indicated
located by A- will
not pass through.
The HA form will
pass through.
Here it is on
the other side,
dissociating
dependent on the
pKa and the pH
of the fluid in
the body
compartment it's in.
Weak base,
the protonated form
will not pass through.
The non-protonated
B form will
pass through and
same concept,
just the weak
base this time.
This figure here
at the top shows
the pKa right here
in the middle.
When the pH equals
the pKa then And the
both forms, the
ionized and non-ionized
forms, are in equal
concentration.
Let's say the pKa
of the weak acid is
right here. It doesn't
have to be right
here. Let's say it's
right here. Then we
have an increasing
amount of the ionized
form as we move up.
An increasing amount
of the non-ionized
form as we move down.
But very few areas
in the body have a pH
so low. The one
exception is the stomach.
Let's say we have a weak
base of, let's say here.
then the majority
of it will be in the
ionized form BH
plus but as the pH
increases the majority
will be in the B
non-ionized form but
there the pH is in
this area are
incompatible with life.
To repeat non-ionized
molecules diffuse
used readily across
the membrane.
So what do we do
with this information
in terms of the
clinical utilization
of it? It's all
very interesting.
It's called ion
trapping. Trapping
of the ionized
form in a fluid
for the purpose, usually,
of increasing the rate of
excretion of a
toxic compound.
We can also talk
about it in terms of
how much drug is
going to be excreted
in a particular pH
of urine versus how
much will stay
in. That can be
therapeutically important,
but not commonly.
Starting on the
left-hand side.
Blood pH, 7.4.
A drug in concentration
of one micromolar
in the non-protonated
form. This is a weak
base we're talking
about in this example.
and the pH with this
example which I took
from the basic and clinical
pharmacology review
book it is a weight
base with a pK of 7.0
the tendency
is to be in the
non-ionized non
-protonated form
and we still of course
get a certain amount
in the protonated form
so between the two
we have one micromole
and the non-protonated
0.4 micromole and the
protonated and here's
the total it is one
drug after all the non
-protonated form readily
crosses the membrane
you see here it can
cross both directions.
The pH of the urine,
however, is 6.0 in
this example, which
is pretty common.
Urine tends to be acidic.
And we see this
thicker arrow
pointing towards
the protonated form.
Lower pH, more of
the molecule of this
weak base will be in
the protonated form.
So, we still have
1 micromole of
the non-protonated,
but we have 11
micromoles of the
protonated form.
Therefore, we
have a greater
amount that's
not passing back
through, indicated
by this arrow.
And it will
pass out through
the urine and
be excreted.
It's a basic idea
of ion trapping.
This is actually
a strategy used
most frequently for
salicylate toxicity.
And salicylate
is a weak acid.
So the whole
idea then would
be to increase
urine pH to 7 or
8, as high as
we can get it,
so that we can trap
the salicylate in the
urine and excrete it
at a greater rate.
Let's talk about
transporters now.
That's another way for
drugs to pass through
physiologic barriers.
Not all drugs have
the lipid solubility
to be able to actually
pass through the
bilayer. So there are
transporters. And these
transporters, of course,
are present because our
natural body processes
require them, but the
drugs use them also.
Now,
membrane transporters
are selective,
so a drug must
actually need to be a
substrate of the
transporter in order
for it to pass through
the transporter.
and it is selective
for a specific
conformational
structure of the
drug. That's
basically what we're
talking about,
being a substrate.
They are saturable
because they are
doors. They are
doors across the
membrane and if
they're busy, then
other drugs can't
pass through them.
their expression can be
increased or decreased
just like metabolic
enzymes they are
subject to competitive
inhibition as i said before
if they are busy
another substrate is not
going to be able to
pass through it because
it's busy it's saturated
all of them saturated
It's not just one
transporter, there are
probably hundreds of
thousands, at least.
It is also subject
to non-competitive
inhibition. In other
words, a drug that
binds to an allosteric
site can change
the conformation of
the transporter such
that the substrate
is unable to bind.
Excuse me, I pushed
the wrong button.
Genetic variance.
Well we all have our
certain appearances
based on our genes
and the transporters
can be subject
to mutations that
increase or decrease
their effects.
There is a potential
for adverse effects
and drug interactions
based on the fact
that they can be
induced, down-regulated,
competitive inhibition,
non-competitive
inhibition, and
genetic variants.
This figure
here shows that
transporters really
are everywhere.
There are two major
families, the SLC
or solute carrier
family. These are
the carrier proteins,
the channels,
secondary active
transporters.
The carrier proteins
and channels just allow
passive diffusion,
facilitative diffusion
and passive diffusion,
down the concentration
gradient without the
requirement of energy.
The drug molecule just
moves through until
the concentrations on
both sides are equal.
And then it
would be no net
movement, a dynamic
equilibrium.
And I'm writing this
again so you
don't forget.
Secondary active
transporters are the type
where two or more
substances will use that
same transporter. One
substance, frequently
sodium, moves down its
concentration gradient,
in this case
electrochemical gradient,
that supplies the
energy for the
movement of
another substance.
And the ABC
superfamily, ATP.
All you have to really
remember is AATP.
AATP. ATP
requires energy.
I mean, it
supplies energy.
for primary
active transport
against the
concentration gradient.
The ATPase is the
enzyme that catalyzes
ATP hydrolysis supplying
the energy. The
ABC superfamily
of primary active
transporters provide active
efflux of xenobiotics,
products that we
put into our body
that are not natural
to the body and get
pushed back against
the concentration
gradient. A typical
example would be the
intestine, where the
drug goes into the
epithelial cells
and gets pushed back
into the lumen. It
should go like this.
And the liver.
There are active
transporters for biliary
excretion to push them
out of the hepatocytes
into the biliary
system. for excretion.
Kidney, same thing. Blood
-brain barrier,
and on and on.
Point out this
little figure
here. This is,
I believe, to
represent the
placental barrier,
but I could be
wrong about that.
Maybe you can tell.
Here we have figures
of the various types of
transporters. We have
carrier protein and
facilitated transport
channel, all these
various solute carrier
types of transporters for
passive transport,
facilitated transport.
And our active
transporters, this is called
a sodium potassium
ATPase, and that is
the motor that powers
active transport.
Here's our ATP,
goes to ADP,
releases that
phosphate with energy.
This is an example
of ion channels,
sodium ATPase
again, sodium
potassium ATPase
supplying the power,
sodium then goes down
the concentration
gradient and that
supplies the energy
for the movement,
in this case of
bicarbonate, and in
this case of an active,
sorry, this is an
antipower, it goes the
different direction,
the opposite
direction. And this is
some other molecule.
Passive transport,
secondary active
transport, and primary
active transport.
The p-glycoprotein
is one of
the most well
-studied ATPases.
It is, this is a
picture of it. You don't
have to memorize
what it looks like.
You don't have to
recreate that. What you
do need to know is
that P-glycoprotein
is an ATP-dependent
pump, active efflux
of drugs from the
cell. We'll be talking
about this over and
over and over and
over because it
is essential for
understanding certain
drug-drug interactions.
P-glycoprotein is located
on the apical side
of plasma membranes
right next to lumens.
It is expressed in
intestine, liver,
kidney, brain capillaries,
placenta, other
tissues. It is
expressed on tumor
cells and confers
multi-drug resistance.
And there are certain
efflux transporters
on bacteria that pump
our antibiotics out.
A little bit of a review.
The practice
questions give more
interesting questions
for application
of the knowledge.
This is just a
check your knowledge
review, and I
recommend that you
pause the computer,
answer them in
your own words from
your own memory,
and then after you
try, look it
up, and then try
answering from your
own memory again.
So please pause
if you wish.
And coming back now,
what physicochemical
property determines the
ability of a drug to
passively diffuse
through lipid membranes?
By what mechanism
can a hydrophilic
drug cross
physiologic barriers?
For drugs that
are weak acids and
weak bases, why
is the pH of a
biologic fluid
clinically important?
And here are the answers.
The lipid water
coefficient of a
drug, which is the
ratio of the drug
in the lipid and
the aqueous phases,
determines how
readily the drug
molecule moves across
lipid membranes.
Lipid-soluble
drugs passively
diffuse through the lipid
membranes, which
are not saturable.
The rate of transfer, I'm
always talking
about rates,
across the membranes
from an area
of higher
concentration to lower
concentration is
directly proportional
to the lipid
water coefficient.
A hydrophilic drug
can cross physiologic
barriers via
transport proteins.
Passive diffusion or
facilitated transport
down the concentration
gradient.
Or energy using
active transport.
That would be
secondary and primary.
Transporters are
saturable. When all the
transporters are occupied,
then nothing else
can get through until
they are unoccupied.
They are at their
maximum rate of transfer.
Weak acids and weak
bases either gain or
lose electrical charge
-bearing protons, depending
on their pKa and the
pH of the medium.
only the uncharged
form of the drug will
passively diffuse across
the lipid bilayer while
the charged form does
not this is called
ion ion trapping
manipulation of urine ph may
be appropriate for
increasing the rate of
excretion by ion
trapping of certain drugs
such as toxic concentrations
of salicylates.
Okay, so how do we
introduce the drug
into the body? Looking
at this figure,
it's easy to see
that basically by any
method, any *******
and injection into
everywhere,
basically.
Skin, veins,
arteries,
spine,
ventricles.
Selection of the
root is determined by
the properties of the
drug and therapeutic
objectives. What
is the goal of
therapy? How quickly
does the drug need
to be on board in
therapeutic levels.
I'm not going to
go through every
single route of
administration.
I have a table at
the end of this
PowerPoint with the
benefits and disadvantages
of all of the
various routes of
administration. You
do need to know it.
need to know this
is medicine. This is
how you are going
to administer drugs
to your patient. So
this is straightforward,
and you can look
through that
on your own. You do
need to learn it.
This is a quick
overview. enteral roots
either so going through
the mouth basically
or an enteral tube
or at the other
end rectally going into
the gut now sublingual
and buckle go into
the mouth this
is tongue under the
tongue this is between
the gum and cheek
but they pass through
the mucous membranes
of the mouth into
the venous drainage
of the oral cavity.
The upper small
intestine, upper
small intestine, is
the major site of
oral drug absorption
because the
intestine is made for
absorption. That's
its job. It's an
absorptive organ.
The stomach is
not an absorptive
organ. It is a
digestive organ.
Parenteral, so drugs
that are injected.
I've indicated all the
various routes
of injection.
Topical, we think
of topical as
application for
local effect.
Skin comes to mind
readily, eyes, ears.
Lungs,
people who take
inhalers for
lung disease.
we're applying the
drug directly
to lung tissue.
Gut, if the drug
is not absorbed and
stays in the gut,
it can actually
be used topically
for gut problems.
And transdermal, this
is transmucosal here,
transdermal is
topical, however it's
intended to pass
through the skin
layers for systemic
circulation.
This little figure
shows where the
needle is injected
for various
parenteral roots
through the skin.
So that's all I'm
going to say about
absorption and
administration, or I
should say routes
of administration,
so please do learn
that on your own.
So distribution
is the process by
which a drug
reversibly leaves the
bloodstream
and enters the
interstitial and
intracellular fluids.
Moving through the
body, two targets.
First pass effect,
bioavailability, and
extent of distribution.
The first pass
effect is merely how
much of the drug that's
taken ****** will
pass through the gut
into the portal
circulation, pass through
the liver and be
metabolized within the
liver. So first pass
effect is basically
the inactivation by
drug metabolism and
a certain percent will
then be distributed
however much manages
to get through
that process to the
systemic circulation.
So the first pass
effect just to
reiterate so you won't
be confused, is about
the inactivation by
drug metabolizing.
Enzymes of oral
drugs, because they
pass through the
liver first before
going into the
systemic circulation.
Now bioavailability
is the amount
that actually
passes through and
gets to the systemic
circulation.
so it is the fraction
of the dose of the
active drug that
reaches the systemic
circulation so a drug
that is taken ******
and is completely
metabolized through by
the liver on the first
pass is not a useful
drug because very
little of it will
get to the systemic
circulation So, all
drugs that are oral
must have some degree
of bioavailability in
order to be useful.
the rate and extent of
distribution through
the body is determined
by for the i don't
know how many times
now 25th time or
something the physical
physical chemical
properties of the
drug and the patient's
physiologic factors is
the patient young and
healthy? Does the
patient have adequate
cardiac output, adequate
regional blood flow?
How is the capillary
permeability? That's
how drugs get into
interstitial spaces.
And what is the volume
of this patient,
the tissue volume?
How large are
they? How much muscle
mass do they have?
How much fat mass
do they have, etc.
Now redistribution,
that's certainly
an important concept
in distribution.
We'll talk about
redistribution.
This is so boards
relevant. So
what is it? What
we're talking
about is one dose
of a highly lipid
soluble drug. So
what kind of drug
is that? Let's
say an anesthetic.
That's when we
talk about it most
frequently. So we're
talking about one
dose of an anesthetic.
We might be
talking about an
anti-seizure drug.
So we see on this figure,
the peak is right here.
So if it's an oral
drug, it's going to
be a lag time. But
let's talk about an
IV drug. It's administered
IV, gets right
away into the
bloodstream, and it will
be carried
through the body
to the highly
perfused organs.
So VRG stands for
vessel-rich group.
And what is the
vessel-rich group that
we're concerned with
with an anesthetic?
The brain, CNS, brain,
and spinal cord.
All right, this
one dose of
drug travels to the brain
and because the
brain tissue has no
molecules in it at
that moment and the
concentration in blood
is high, the drug will
move down its
concentration gradient into
the CNS tissues and
produce its effects.
And as the drug
does that and
moves through
the body, the
concentration in
drug now decreases.
At the same time, the
vessel-rich group,
including the CNS, is
taking up the drug.
So the concentration
increases in the vessel
-rich group, decreases
in the bloodstream,
there's only a certain
amount that has to go
around to everywhere,
produces its effect.
And as the
bloodstream, as
the drug in
blood is reduced,
you see it's even
going into the
skeletal muscles
here, but much
more slowly because
they're less
perfused than the
vessel-rich group.
Now the drug is
moving out of the CNS
tissues back into
the blood because the
concentration gradient
in the blood is lower.
Okay,
and drug moves to
the other tissues
based on the level
or perfusion. So the
point is, with
redistribution, the drug
produces its CNS
effect very rapidly.
And with the one dose,
as the concentration
in plasma decreases,
the CNS effect decreases,
decreased CNS effect.
This phenomenon
occurs primarily
when one dose
of highly lipid
-soluble drug
acting on the brain
and spinal cord is
administered rapidly
by intravenous injection
or by inhalation.
Many anesthetics,
well, a few
anesthetics are
by inhalation.
The drug rapidly
distributes to the CNS,
moves down the
concentration gradient into
the CNS tissues, and
produces its effect.
The drug then moves
back into the blood
as it is taken up
by the less vascular
tissues, which, and
here's the key point,
terminates the
CNS effect.
But, IV administration
of drug moves to
CNS, produces its
effect, then it quickly
terminates the CNS
effect as it moves
out of the CNS
tissue back into the
bloodstream. Now,
this is not related to
the drug moving out
of the body, being
excreted by the
body. It's just the
redistribution into
the peripheral tissues.
That's the concept.
Termination of
CNS effect of
this highly lipid
-soluble drug.
One dose by
redistribution
to the peripheral
tissues.
That's it.
Distribution across
the placenta. The fetus
is to some extent
exposed to all drugs,
or nearly all drugs,
taken by the mother.
Placental transfer
of drugs across the
placenta may cause
anomalies in the developing
fetus. So the general
determinants of
drugs that can produce
important levels
in the fetus's
bloodstream, systemic
circulation, are the
lipid solubility of the
drug. If it's lipid
-soluble, it can, as
you know, can cross
physiologic membranes.
If the drug is
highly protein-bound,
then there is a
lower amount of free
drug that can
cross the lipid
membranes. But it
could still be enough.
Fetal plasma is
slightly more acidic
than the mother,
so thinking
about ion-trapping
of basic drugs.
P-glycoprotein and other
export transporters
are part of that blood
placenta barrier.
So they function
to limit the fetal
exposure of certain
drugs. Drugs that
are substrates of
poor P-glycoprotein.
Now drug reservoirs.
I've mentioned this
a few times by now.
Drug reservoirs
and other, think
about storage
sites, storage.
Reversible binding,
and that's how
these are. The
drugs are 99.999999%
reversible binding
to the inert plasma
proteins and inert
tissue macromolecules
tends to sequester
the drug in those
compartments. So
what does that mean?
Drugs on inert
molecules are not free.
They are not free
to be metabolized.
to be excreted. They
are not free to
travel to their
site of action or
anywhere else. They
are riding around
on the albumin bus.
Albumin is the major
plasma protein that
we're thinking about
when it comes to
sequestering of drugs
on plasma proteins.
Drugs that bind to tissue
macromolecules stay
in the tissues.
Now this is
reversible, don't
forget, reversible
binding.
So the drugs can be on
and off and on and off.
And the extent
depends on their
affinity for those
plasma proteins
and the concentration
of drug.
Looking at our plasma
protein concept here,
we have our drug protein
complex and free drug.
This is in dynamic
equilibrium at
steady state.
So steady state
occurs with continuous
dosing. Either it's an
IV dose that's going
in by continuous
infusion or it's dosed
by any route of
administration that goes in
at a frequency, at
a regular frequency.
So that's what we
mean by continuous
dosing. And it
gets to the point
where there is
dynamic equilibrium.
Here's our free
drug molecules in
plasma in this figure,
and you can see
they pass through the
spaces and capillaries
and they move
into the tissues.
The bound drug does not.
That's the basic idea.
We'll talk more about
that in a future lecture.
Oh, sorry.
Okay.
Okay, so some of
the features of drug
binding to these inert
molecules, meaning
they don't have a
regulatory effect,
they're important,
but they don't cause,
when they're, they
don't have, they're
not activated and
producing some
biologic effect as on
molecules, on cells.
drug binding is non
-selective so that
means a wide variety
of different chemical
structures can
be bound to the
plasma protein it's
variable saturable
there are only just
so many molecules of
albumin floating
around in the blood it
is non-linear meaning
it's saturable
and it is reversible.
So on and off
and on and off
in a dynamic equilibrium.
The fraction bound is
determined by how much
drug there is. So the
drug concentration.
What is the affinity
of that plasma protein
for the drug? If
it has no affinity,
it won't bind the
drug. or it might have
high affinity and
bind the drug tightly,
but it's usually
somewhere in the middle.
And albumin has a
number of binding sites.
It could be
binding a number of
different molecules
at the same time.
So if there are
a large number,
then it's got a big
capacity to bind
drugs. If there's
a small number
available, then a
smaller capacity.
Competition and
disease related factors
can determine the
extent of drug binding.
So here's a check
your knowledge
and perhaps you
would like to
pause the video
and try and answer
these on your own.
So you may pause now.
and welcome back. I hope
you gave this
some thought.
Oral drugs are
absorbed mainly
from what part
of the intestine?
What is the clinical
significance of the
phenomenon of redistribution
when applied to
highly lipophilic drugs
such as anesthetics?
What is the concern
about drugs that
can cross the blood
placenta barrier?
And what is the
clinical relevance
of drug binding to plasma
proteins and tissue
macromolecules.
Drugs are absorbed
mainly from the
upper small intestine,
which has a very
large surface
area for absorbing
nutrients and drugs,
because of villi along
the length of the
small intestine.
The redistribution
refers to a drug that
will go immediately
to the CNS, produce
the CNS effect,
and as the drug is
redistributed to the
peripheral tissue,
the plasma concentration
of the drug is
reduced and the CNS
effect is diminished.
Drugs able to cross the
blood placenta barrier
can lead to fetal
exposure of the drug.
Practitioners need to
know what drugs are
safe, what drugs are
toxic to the fetus, and
at which stages of the
pregnancy. This is a
must-know that we will
talk about as we go
through these various
drug classes later on.
Plasma proteins
and tissue
macromolecules
are inert. They do
not regulate
cellular actions.
Drugs reversibly bound
to plasma proteins
or tissue macromolecules
are sequestered.
They're not free
to be metabolized,
excreted, or reach
the site of action.
As the concentration
of free drug decreases
due to elimination,
drug molecules
dissociate, which
maintains the free drug
concentration at a
constant fraction.
And in summary, this
is a little mind
map of the
pharmacokinetic processes.
The physicochemical
characteristics of
a drug determine its
ability to withstand
digestive fluids
and enzymes and be
absorbed from the
GI tract, cross
physiologic barriers,
survive metabolic
processes. distribute
to the site of action
in therapeutic
concentrations and exit
the site of action
and be eliminated.
Drugs move along
their concentration
gradients by passive
diffusion across the
lipid bilayer of
cell membranes or by
carrier or channel
-mediated transport.
Drugs may also be
pumped out by energy
-dependent active
transport. very large
or lipid-insoluble
drugs may enter or exit
cells by endocytosis
or pinocytosis,
which I didn't actually
mention before.
This applies to
so few drugs.
The rate and extent of
flow of drug molecules
are influenced by
the magnitude of a
concentration gradient
across the membrane, lipid
solubility, that is
to say lipid water
partition coefficient,
membrane surface area,
thickness, and
permeability. Weak acids and
weak bases are present
in solution as both a
non-ionized and ionized
species. The non
-ionized molecules usually
are more lipid soluble
and can diffuse
readily across the cell
membrane, whereas the
ionized molecules usually
are less able to
********* the lipid
membrane because of their
low lipid solubility.
Transmembrane
distribution is
determined by the
drugs pKa and the
pH gradient across
the membrane.
Different routes
of administration
are used in clinical
medicine for
various reasons,
such as convenience,
rapid onset of
action, maximizing
concentration at
the site of action,
avoiding first
-pass effect,
and minimizing
adverse effects.
The rate and extent
of drug distribution
are determined by
the physico-chemical
properties of the drug and
the physiologic factors
of cardiac output,
regional blood flow,
capillary permeability,
and tissue volume.
Extensive binding to
inert proteins and
other macromolecules
may slow the rate at
which a drug reaches
the site of action
and may prolong the
duration of action as
the drugs are sequestered
in the tissues.
These are the tables
I mentioned before.
It tells you the
root, the absorption
pattern, what
they're useful
for, and potential
disadvantages.
There are lots of
roots. Most of this is
intuitive. you probably
know it already,
but you do need to know
it. As a physician,
it's so so important
to be able to
select the right route
of administration.
And that concludes
part one of our
pharmacokinetics
ADME, administration,
distribution, metabolism,
and excretion.
Welcome, students, to
Pharmacokinetics Part 2,
Principles of Metabolism
and Excretion.
And we will also talk
about the individual
variation in
response to drugs. We
talk about the big
picture, and then
we'll drill down to
what happens that can
cause changes in
our expectation to
drug response in the
individual patient.
Dr. Goldstein speaking.
please contact me if
you'd like to have a
chat about pharmacology
individuals and
groups are welcome
here are the learning
objectives mechanisms
mechanisms mechanisms
and these is all
about bio elimination
elimination by
biotransformation in other words
metabolism and
elimination by excretion.
My suggestions,
and please do
the practice
questions, they
will help you.
Here are some links
you might find
helpful if you
wish to use them.
I talked about the
key elements of
metabolism and
excretion in In
part one, this is
what we'll cover.
And let us begin
with the general
principles of
drug metabolism.
These are enzyme
-catalyzed conversion
of our drug, a
chemical, to some other
molecule, some other
chemical. We have
many, many protein
drugs that have been
developed in the
past 20 or 25 years.
Protein drugs are
subject to metabolism as
other proteins are,
proteolytic cleavage.
We need to also be
thinking about the
individual patient in
terms of pharmacogenomics.
People do have
variabilities in the
expression of their
various metabolic enzymes.
We'll talk about phase
1 and phase 2 reactions.
The genetic factors,
as I said, and we'll
also talk about
inhibition and induction,
which are mechanisms
of drug interactions.
Super important
concept. We'll go
into that more in
later lectures.
the liver is the
principal organ of drug
metabolism drug
metabolism concurrent can
occur in many tissues
but the liver is
actually built to do
that it has a large
blood flow it has a portal
circulation directly
from the intestines
to the liver it
has open spaces
sinusoidal fenestrations,
they're called, allowing
the blood to bring
all sorts of substances
into the liver,
high concentration
of metabolic enzymes,
of transporters,
both the solute
carrier type and the
primary active that
use ATP for energy.
Solute carriers
are located in the
basolateral membrane
where they can allow
substrates to go
into the hepatocytes.
and ABC transporters,
our ATP type, are
located in the bile
canalicular system
in order to expulse
or efflux drugs
into the biliary
system for excretion.
This is just a quick
scheme. I will keep
talking about the
portal system.
Looking on the left
-hand side, the spleen,
stomach, pancreas,
small intestine,
colon, the whole
intestine drains into the
portal vein, which
goes to the liver.
The liver then goes
via the vena cava into
the heart, the right
atrium, and gets
cycled through the
heart, and the left
ventricle pushes blood
into the aorta, which
then leads to delivering
blood through the
arterial system to
all parts of the body.
This figure
shows the liver
and the gallbladder
underneath.
gallbladder squeezes
out the bile acids
when a person eats a
fatty meal bile acids
go into the duodenum
to emulsify that
fat for digestion and
it travels through
this is representing
the entire small
intestine to the
terminal ileum where the
bile acids the large
majority of bile acids
are then reabsorbed
back into the portal
vein, back into the
liver, where they
get recycled back
into the gallbladder.
Very efficient system.
If a drug enters the
gallbladder through
the bile canalicular
system, that
also will go back
into the intestine.
and if it's a certain
metabolic product
like a glucuronide
then that may
actually be reactivated
which I'll go into
back into the portal
vein but otherwise
it just gets
excreted in the feces
and this is a picture
an illustration of
the liver lobule to
kind of give you the
landmarks to to be able
to visualize what's
going on in the liver
that you don't have to
memorize that I just
wanted to explain the
portal system and how
important that is when
we're talking about
drugs especially oral
drugs drugs may be
biotransformed to inactive
active or toxic
metabolites or more
hydrophilic readily
excretable products drugs
can also pass through
the liver unchanged
what happens is for
effective drugs that
pass through the liver
a certain fraction
of them will be
secreted unchanged
into the systemic
circulation and therefore
be available to
produce their effect.
Drug enters hepatocyte
through transporter,
solute carrier
transporter.
Drug has a number
of different
metabolic pathways
it can go into.
Phase one to a metabolite,
that metabolite
may be secreted into
the bile canaliculus
or it may just be
forming a metabolite
or two metabolites
or a variety of
metabolites and be secreted
into the bloodstream,
into the systemic
circulation. These
are most frequently
inactive, so they
would be excreted,
usually in the kidney.
These are excreted in
the feces, anything
that goes through
the bile canaliculi.
The drug may also go
straight to phase 2
and be secreted as
a metabolite, an
inactive metabolite
usually, vastly more
frequently as an an
active metabolite than
something that has
some sort of activity.
Or that metabolite
may be secreted into
the bile canaliculus.
And this is most
frequently the glucuronide
metabolite that
gets secreted into
the bile canaliculi.
Not exclusively,
but most frequently.
The drug can
be excreted as
is into the
bile canaliculi.
The drug can be excreted
as is into the
bloodstream.
So we have all of these
different options.
The vast majority of
drugs, though, will
undergo some level
of metabolism in the
liver. And if these
are oral drugs, they
will undergo on the
first pass through.
So let's talk about
first pass metabolism.
This is also called
first pass effect.
Drug gets swallowed,
goes to stomach,
goes to small
intestine where it is
absorbed. and it
enters the portal
circulation ah but there
are metabolic enzymes
in the epithelial
cells of the gut
and the drug may be
metabolized also in
the gut not all
drugs but some drugs
the drug gets to the
liver and it undergoes
metabolism to some
degree which i will
talk about more in
a future lecture so
because this is oral
administration and
goes to the liver
first it's called first
pass effect or first
pass metabolism or
first pass hepatic
metabolism all of those
are the same meaning,
the same process.
Any drug that actually
leaves the liver as
active drug into the
systemic circulation will
then produce its
effect and the fraction
that enters the systemic
circulation is called
the bioavailability
of the drug it is
available biologically
to produce its biological
effect so first pass
metabolism first pass
effect so let's talk
about phase one metabolic
reactions these are
oxidation reduction
and hydrolysis what happens
here is a functional
group is exposed
something like this
these are pretty typical
and that will most
frequently it caused
inactivation of the drug
molecule which may then
be secreted and into
the systemic circulation
and excreted or
secreted into the biliary
system and excreted.
Sometimes an active
metabolite is formed.
That active metabolite
goes into the systemic
circulation and
produces an effect and
is eventually
inactivated through
other metabolic
processes.
Toxic metabolites
can form.
Sometimes the product
will undergo phase two
because it's not
soluble enough to be
excreted as a hydrophilic
compound in the kidney.
So we have all these
different options.
The cytochrome P450
mixed function oxidase
system are really
the most frequent
phase one metabolic
reactions. It's
this big super family
it's called and
they're referred to as
CYPs. I refer to them
as CYPs. Many people
call them CYPs.
They are abundant in
the liver. They're
present in many other
tissues. They are located
on the lipophilic
membranes of the smooth
endoplasmic reticulum.
So they're kind of
hanging out right
there on the membranes.
And when a substrate
passes by and binds to
it, it will then
metabolize that molecule.
They have low
substrate specificity.
That means that
they're capable
of metabolizing
many, many, many,
many different
types of substrates.
And that's not all they
do, not just drugs.
They're also involved
in the metabolism
of steroids and fatty
acids and many other
products in our body,
natural products.
Heme is required.
Heme has iron in
it, and iron is
essential for the
action of the CYPs.
I'll explain that
on the next slide.
They are susceptible
to inhibition and
induction. In
other words, if a
substrate is present
on the active site of
the CYP and another
drug comes along,
the second drug
will not be able
to access the
active site and will
therefore pass
by unmetabolized.
When there is significant
inhibition of CYPs,
there can be an increase
in the bioavailability,
an increase in the
amount of drug that
actually reaches the
systemic circulation.
So there is a higher
concentration of drug in
the systemic circulation.
And remember, the
amount of drug in the
systemic circulation
determines the amount
of drug at the site of
action, which in turn
determines the magnitude
of the effect. So
this is a drug interaction
that could lead to
increased effect
toxicity adverse effects.
Induction, on the other
hand, is an increase
in the number of
enzymes available. As
a result, the rate
of drug metabolism
increases, which can
lower the amount of drug
that reaches the
systemic circulation.
And we also have
pharmacogenetic
mutations in drug
metabolism. That's
really what this
is all about.
Where the enzyme
is changed somehow
compared to the
majority of the
population. Perhaps it
is under-functioning.
Perhaps it is
over-functioning.
The mechanism of
CYPs, as I said,
they're embedded
in the membrane
of the endoplasmic
reticulum.
And here's a blow up
of that they have this
heme inside and it
is the heme that's
essential for this
oxidative reaction here's
our substrate it's
going to bump into our
drug metabolizing enzyme
and be metabolized
and here's the process
a A reducing agent
is required, and here
we have our reductase.
We also need oxygen,
and of course the drug.
So the drug plus
the reducing agent
will, well, let
me start here.
Here's drug.
Step number one. It goes
through the process,
picks up an electron,
picks up oxygen,
and becomes oxidized.
you do not have to
memorize this whole cycle
this is the part you
need to remember the
drug the oxygen the
reducing agent produces
the metabolite let's
check your knowledge
i invite you to pause
the video see if
you can answer these
questions without
looking them up and
then go ahead and look
them up and try and
answer them again
okay let's look at the
answer CYP metabolism
requires what three
elements heme the
reducing agent NADPH and
oxygen CYP 450 enzymes
are called mono
oxygenases adds an oxygen
CYPs are susceptible
to alteration in
rates of drug
elimination, rates, rates,
everything in pharmacokinetics
is about rates,
by what?
Inhibition or
induction of CYPs
and by pharmacogenetic or
pharmacogenomics
variabilities.
How do these alterations
potentially affect
patient care?
Alterations in plasma
drug concentrations
can lead to increased
potential for
toxicity by inhibition
or an under-functioning
enzyme, or reduced
efficacy by induction
or an ultra-rapidly
functioning enzyme.
How is a knowledge of
clinically relevant
pharmacokinetic
properties of drugs
essential for
patient care. This is
why we're learning
about all of this.
Mechanisms of drug
interactions and effects
of organ function on
plasma drug levels.
Because it is
the drug levels
that determine the
levels at the site of
action that determines
the magnitude of effect.
Efficacy and the
potential for adverse
effects. The right
drug and the right dose
for the right duration
for optimal outcomes.
Please make this part
of your second nature.
all right phase two
metabolic reactions
now these transfer
hydrophilic group
to the substrate
increasing its polarity
and the products
are really almost
always 99.9 percent
of the time inactive.
These are conjugation
reactions. They
transfer a molecule, a
hydrophilic molecule,
from a cofactor and
place it on the drug
or metabolite. So
they're transferring.
The enzymes, therefore,
are transferases.
This example is UDP
-glucuronaciltransferase
or glucuronal
transferase. Both
terms are correct.
Which is the major
transferase in the Phase
II armamentarium of
metabolic reactions.
UGT1A1 is a
pretty common one.
This is how
they are called.
UDP,
glucuronaciltransferase,
UGT for short.
And that's all there
is to it. It takes
molecule from a
donor and attaches
it to the drug
molecule or metabolite.
That's it.
Hydrophilic, excretion,
usually through
the kidney.
These are the six
different transferases.
So UGT I mentioned
was the major one.
It gets its glucuronic
acid from UDP,
uridine diphosphate,
glucuronic acid.
You do not need
to memorize
the names of
the cofactors.
get the idea that they
are bringing along
the hydrophilic molecule
to be transferred
to the drug or
metabolite. You do
need to know the name
of the transferases.
So we have UGT,
UDP-glucuronacil
transferase, or glucuronal
transferase, both
are correct. A
sulfotransferase, transferring
a sulfate. You
do need to know
what gets transferred,
not the cofactor.
And acetyltransferase,
we will be
talking about
this plenty of
times because of
pharmacogenetics.
So acetyl, naturally.
Methyltransferase,
transfers methyl.
Glutathione.
super important in
our bodies because
this catalyzes the
nucleophilic attack of
glutathione on
electrophilic atoms and
xenobiotics and toxic
metabolites so what's
all of that all of
that that were all
those words what is
the take-home message
it detoxifies reactive
oxygen species.
And when we run
out of glutathione
S transferase
because of starvation
or serious, serious
illness, then
these toxic metabolites
can hurt us.
Glycine is a
little amino acid.
It's seen
occasionally. It's not
really one of the
major pathways.
Anyway, these are
all hydrophilic
metabolites that
result and they
can be readily
excreted in urine.
Now let's talk about
enterohepatic circulation
and we'll talk about
them as glucuronide
metabolites which is
the vast majority.
Here on the left
is a picture of the
arrangement of the
organs and the liver.
Stomach, so food
goes in here.
Small intestine,
large intestine.
Here is the portal
circulation draining
all of these organs
and the veins,
the venous circulation
in the liver.
Okay, so that's how
it's set up. So what
we're going to be talking
about with enteroepatic
circulation is as
the drug travels from
the gallbladder, which
is in here underneath
the liver, into the
duodenum and travels
through the small
intestine, and it gets down
here, it will then be
reabsorbed into the
portal circulation and
go back to the liver.
okay so what's
happening drug
gets swallowed drug gets
absorbed from the
small intestine
goes to the liver
via the portal system
gets a glucuronide stuck
on it that glucuronide
metabolite goes into
the biliary system
and gets stored in
the gallbladder along
with bile acids
Now, somebody eats a
fatty meal, and the
glucuronide metabolite is
excreted along with
the bile acids and
transported in this
really very simple figure
here, down here to
the terminal ileum.
So that glucuronide
group is cleaved
off by intestinal
bacteria
flora, which are
populating this area
and the whole
large intestine.
When that glucuronide
gets cleaved off, we
now have active
drug again, and it's
lipophilic. So by passive
diffusion, it goes back
into the portal
system and back to the
liver where it may
be undergo this same
situation again. But we
need to remember it's
not 100% of the drug
that gets metabolized.
I don't know what
percentage it
is, so I'll make
up a percentage.
Let's say 50% of the
original drug got
metabolized and goes
into the gallbladder
and blah, blah,
blah and around the
circle. So, now, what's
coming back in will
get metabolized about
50% of that, and
all of this goes
into the bloodstream.
The other 50%
goes into the
bloodstream as
active drug.
Therefore, with
enterohepatic
circulation, that
can contribute to the
levels in the
systemic circulation.
So that's the
takeaway message with
enterohepatic
circulation of drugs.
well i keep talking
about all these various
enzymes so what
role do they play in
metabolism each individual
one on this figure we
see the cyp3a4 and 5s
the cyp3a family is
about 50% of the CYP
oxidative metabolism.
Different sources have
different fractions,
but the point is they
all agree that the
majority of CYP activity
is by CYP3A family.
CYP2D6 plays a pretty
decent portion.
We'll talk about that
with pharmacogenomics
at a later
time, and we see
little slices from
all these others.
UGT here also
is the majority
of the transferase
activity.
Sulfates has a
pretty good size,
glutathione,
N-acetyltransferase,
and all the rest.
You don't have to
memorize this, just take
away the points that
CYP3A family and UDP
glucuronal transferase
are very, very
important pathways. But
so are the others, they
just don't handle
quite as much traffic.
All right, check
your knowledge.
I, again, invite you
to pause the computer,
take a look at
these questions, see
if you can answer
them without looking.
Okay, let us return now.
How do phase 2 reactions
differ from phase
1 reactions?
Think of three ways.
Phase I reactions
are oxidation.
Phase II are conjugation.
Phase I expose a
functional group.
Phase II transfer
a hydrophilic
substance from
a cofactor.
Phase I
metabolites may be
inactive, active, toxic.
Phase II metabolites
are hydrophilic,
readily excreted, and
almost always inactive.
True or false?
Phase II reactions
must follow Phase
I reactions.
No, that's
false, of course.
Drugs that have a
polar functional group
already exposed on their
structures may directly
undergo a Phase II
conjugation reaction.
What types of drug
metabolites frequently
undergo enteropatic
circulation? The
glucuronide metabolites,
which may go
through the kidney, or
they may be secreted
into the biliary
system by P
-glycoprotein efflux or
by passive diffusion.
These are two
methods by which
drugs get into the
biliary system.
Bacteria that express
beta-glucuronidase
cleave the
glucuronide, releasing
free drug, which is
then reabsorbed by
passive diffusion in
the terminal ileum.
Excretion now.
The kidney is by far
the most frequent
route of excretion
of drugs and
metabolites and lots
of other things.
They eliminate
polar compounds
more efficiently
than substances
with high lipid
solubility.
Renal drug handling.
They may be filtered
from the blood in the
glomerulus. So let's
say this is the
glomerulus. This is drug
going in through the
afferent arteriole.
The blood goes through
the capillary system
in the glomerulus and
goes out through the
efferent arteriole.
And meanwhile, the
plasma gets filtered by
this capillary system
that has fenestrations
or spaces in between
the capillaries, and
the drug or metabolites
go into the nephron.
Another way to get
them in, because
plasma, only about
20% of plasma
gets filtered at
any pass through.
There is a tubular
capillary network that
goes around the nephron.
Don't go by this
picture, it doesn't
really show you, because
it's intended to show
you something else.
Drug in the
bloodstream can also be
secreted into the
nephron. So those
are two pathways
to get in there,
glomerular filtration,
active tubular secretion.
Remember, drugs that
are bound to proteins
are not going to
be able to pass
through the glomerulus,
only free drug.
Okay,
now, drug passes
through the nephron,
various things happen
in the nephron, you'll
learn about that in
the renal system. And
it can get into the
distal tubule where it
can be, if it is
lipophilic and active
drug, it can be
reabsorbed back into the
bloodstream and travel
around the body again.
If not, it will be
excreted in the urine.
That's the basic idea.
glomerular filtration
or active tubular
secretion to get
into the nephron,
passive reabsorption
out of the distal
tubule if it is
lipophilic, and
otherwise it gets
excreted in the urine.
Altering the urinary
pH to favor ionization
can enhance excretion
of charged species,
charged forms of weak
acids or weak bases.
renal function is not
constant even in the
healthy person the
neonate's renal function
is low compared with
body mass but matures
rapidly within the first
few months of birth
adults experience a
slow decline in renal
function inexorable
elderly patients may
have substantial kidney
function impairment,
even if it's not
caused by disease.
And of course,
both acute and
chronic disease can
certainly modify
renal function.
Here's a better picture
of the glomerulus
and the capillary
network inside here.
There are big
spaces, it's kind of
indicated by these
little dots here.
Those are big spaces
where plasma gets
filtered through
into the nephron.
Filtered because it
takes in the plasma and
solutes anything
that's dissolved in
the plasma, but keeps
out the proteins.
Oops, excuse me,
wrong button.
The takeaway here,
this is what you are
expected to remember.
the glomerular filtration
rate is a determinant
of renal function we
will be talking about
renal function when it
comes to drug therapy
over and over and over
and what we're talking
about is the ability
of the glomerulus to
do its filtration job
glomerular
filtration rate is a
useful measure of
renal function there
are limitations
it is a biomarker.
Glomerular filtration
rate is the
sum of all of the
functioning nephrons
and it is a
rough measure of
the number of
functioning nephrons.
The rate of filtration.
Serum creatinine
and creatinine
clearance are
estimates, biomarkers
of glomerular
filtration rate.
Creatinine is the end
product of creatine
metabolism from
skeletal muscle.
Please don't confuse
these two terms.
Creatinine
production is stable.
Creatinine is filtered
through the glomerulus
and a small amount
is secreted and
it's not reabsorbed.
So that's why measuring
creatinine in the
blood or creatinine
in the urine is an
estimate of glomerular
filtration rate. The
rate at which creatinine
passes through is
essentially equal
to GFR. And I'm saying
essentially there
are drawbacks, but
that's a lecture for a
later time. Nonetheless,
it's still a
frequently used indicator
of renal function,
and we use it for
renal dosing, dosing
for individuals who
have renal impairment.
I'm not going to ask
you to memorize these
various equations
and there are a
number of automatic
equations that you can
get where you just
put in the numbers and
the computer will
work it out for you.
Creatinine clearance
is determined by
collecting a timed
urine sample. 24 hours
sample is the
standard of care and
clearance is then
expressed in milliliters
per minute. That's
how we talk about GFR
and milliliters per
minute of clearance.
So let's check the
knowledge again. I invite
you to pause the video
and see if you can
come up with these
answers from your memory.
Okay so let us return.
What are the processes
involved in renal
excretion of drugs
and metabolites?
Molecules not bound to
plasma proteins enter
the kidney via
glomerular filtration or
act of secretion into
the proximal tubule.
If lipophilic, they
may be passively
reabsorbed in the distal
tubule. If not, drugs
and metabolites are
excreted in the urine.
What is the most
frequently used biomarker
of kidney function serum
creatinine also urine
creatinine which requires
a urine collection
over time serum
creatinine is a blood
test glomerular filtration
rate shows how well
the kidneys are filtering
and finally what
is the clinical
relevance of gfr on drug
therapy A low GFR means
kidney function is
impaired, which means
drugs may not be excreted
at the usual rate
and can accumulate in
the blood, increasing
the risk of toxicity.
This is why we care.
Drug therapy may
need to be adjusted,
and we call this
renal dosing.
And finally, variation
in drug response.
Many, many factors
can impact the rate at
which drugs are cleared,
are eliminated, and
these need to be taken
into consideration
when considering
drug therapy for your
individual patient,
whether it's for adjustment
of dosing or possibly
avoiding certain
drugs. This wheel lists
all of these different
things that it could
be and I'd like to
also add to it genetic
variability. Don't
forget about that. This
is becoming much easier
to identify as screening
tests are becoming
more available and
more affordable the
older patient and the
neonates i'll focus
on them for the older
patient there may
be multiple concurrent
diseases that are
going to affect
your drug therapy so
drug disease
interactions intestinal
intestinal motility may
be reduced blood flow
may be reduced muscle
mass may reduced
body fat may be
increased kidney function
reduction liver
function reduction and
then just general
structural and functional
changes in the brain
that can occur.
In the neonate, they
have immature processes,
absorption, distribution,
metabolism,
and excretion.
We have to be
very, very careful
dosing them,
and it should
be left to the
neonatologist.
Blood flow, GI function,
they are just little
bags of water,
especially the
********* babies.
lower plasma protein
binding capacity
because their livers
are not producing them
to the same degree
as in the older
child even the older
infant low activity
of the drug
metabolizing enzymes and
transporters they're
not mature yet lower
glomerular filtration
rate potentially or
even higher glomerular
filtration rate.
So in summary, I have
put you a little mind
map again. If you find
these helpful, make
them yourself. You
can make simple ones.
They don't have to be
complicated and they
can help you connect
the dots as it were.
Here's another one.
And biotransformation
is a complex
process involving
numerous enzyme systems
that usually detoxify
the xenobiotics.
Xeno meaning
foreign or not
occurring naturally
in our bodies.
Phase I reactions include
oxidation, reduction,
hydrolysis. These
processes unmask a
polar functional group.
And the products may
be inactive, usually,
or active or toxic.
Phase II reactions
involve the addition
of a subgroup, and
that's called a
conjugation, with the
drug or metabolite.
These are the
glucuronide, I should
say glucuronide,
not glucuronate,
acetate, sulfate,
methylate,
and glycine groups.
The enzymes that
catalyze the
reactions are
called transferases.
they transfer the
subgroup supplied
by a cofactor
onto the substrate
phase two metabolites
are significantly
more hydrophilic
than the substrate
and are readily
excreted usually
definitely most frequently
in the urine drugs
metabolized by both
phase one and phase
two reactions may undergo
phase 1 before phase
2 or go directly to
phase 2 or there may be
complicated metabolic
reactions occurring.
Drug disposition is also
affected by membrane
transport proteins
which mediate the
cellular uptake and
efflux of xenobiotics in
the liver, kidney, and
many many many other
tissues. The Phase I
CYP enzymes biotransform
most xenobiotics. CYPs
are expressed in a
high concentration in
the membrane of the
smooth endoplasmic
reticulum of the liver and
in lower concentrations
in other tissues.
CYPs are relatively
non-selective. A
small number of P450
isoforms metabolize
thousands and
thousands of drugs.
CYP3A4 is the most
abundant isoform
metabolizing in some
estimates, in most
estimates, about
50% of all drugs.
Enzyme activity can
vary due to concurrent
administration of other
drugs that inhibit
or induce the drug
metabolizing enzymes.
Enzyme inhibition
can reduce the
rate of metabolism
of the substrate
drug, leading to
increased systemic
levels, increased
bioavailability.
Enzyme induction
increases the
rate of metabolism
of the substrates,
reducing bioavailability.
CYP enzyme activity
is quite variable
due to pharmacogenetic
variabilities.
These are genetic
polymorphisms,
in other words,
switches in the
amino acid positions
in the DNA.
So these are genetic
changes that exist
in at least 1% of
the human population.
So this is the study
of pharmacogenomics.
Most drugs are excreted
in urine, either
as the parent compound,
that is to say the
unchanged drug, active
drug, or as metabolites
with polar characteristics.
Minor routes
of excretion include
sweat, saliva, tears,
skin, hair, and
certainly breast milk.
Think baby.
The processes
involved in renal
elimination are
glomerular filtration
and or active
tubular secretion,
passive tubular
reabsorption of
lipophilic drugs,
and then excretion in
urine. Only free
drug molecules, those
that are not bound
to plasma proteins,
are filtered by
the glomerulus.
The concentration of
drug excreted in urine
results from the amount
of drug introduced
to the nephrons through
glomerular filtration
and secretion in
the proximal tubule,
minus the amount
reabsorbed in the distal
tubule, and that gets
excreted, obviously.
Interindividual
variations can affect
the rate and extent
of drug elimination.
Serum creatinine and
creatinine clearance
are biomarkers of
renal function. They
are used to estimate
the glomerular
filtration rate in the
assessment of kidney
function for the
individual patient.
The dose and frequency
of administration
required to achieve
therapeutic blood and
tissue levels vary
in different patients
because of the individual
differences in drug
distribution, rates
of drug metabolism,
and elimination. These
are determined by
genetic factors and non
-genetic variables such
as age, ***, liver
size, liver function,
circadian rhythm,
body temperature,
nutritional,
environmental factors,
concomitant
exposure to inducers
or inhibitors of
drug metabolism.
Here's why we care.
understanding and
employing pharmacokinetic
principles can
increase the probability
of therapeutic
success and reduce the
occurrence of adverse
drug effects in the
body for optimization
of drug therapy
in the individual
patient. Please make
this second nature.
And that concludes
the absorption,
distribution,
metabolism, and excretion
principles of
pharmacokinetics.